et si les yvelinois ne voyait jamais
arrivé la ligne 18 sur leur territoire
voilà une interrogation qui semblait
insensé il ya quelques mois mais qui a
pris corps cet été à la recherche de
plusieurs milliards d'euros d'économies
l'état pourrait annoncer une remise en
cause du projet dans sa partie
yvelinoise un retour en arrière sur fond
de tensions entre départements
franciliens les élus du département
points directement leurs collègues
essonniens qui pousserait l'état se
retirer du dossier
nous avons des bruits qui arrive jusqu'à
nos oreilles comme quoi les
parlementaires essonniens pèserait
auprès du gouvernement pour revoir ces
choses-là dont nous faisons entendre
haut et fort que nous nous voulons cette
ligne 18,6 au napa 2018
on pourra plus continuer à se développer
tout simplement donc plus de
construction de logements plus de
d'entreprise et qui vont venir et donc
on risque d'avoir un déclin de notre
territoire
pour l'heure sans annonce officielle
contraire la ligne 18 du grand paris
express reste un chantier pharaonique de
35 km de métro automatique
traversant trois départements et qui
reliera d'ici 2030 l'aéroport d'orly
dans le val de marne à la gare de
versailles chantiers dans les yvelines
l'état prend des engagements il n'y a
pas de continuité républicaine un
nouveau gouvernement arrive et c'est
plus les mêmes s'engage alors bien
entendu aucun changement gouvernement il
ya des changements de politique mêlée
politique qui s'étale sur 10 15 20 30 au
si l'état ne les respectent pas il se
passe rien à saint quentin en yvelines
en tout cas les travaux préparatoires
sur l'ancien site de thalès qui doit
accueillir la future gare ont débuté en
vue notamment des jeux olympiques de
2024 l'agglomération accueillera
plusieurs compétitions olympiques
enfin à plus court terme la zone doit
servir de point relais pour la ryder cup
prévue dans un an
la préparation donc de ces travaux
amorce finalement le début des travaux
pour la ligne 18 que l'on espère voir
débuter en 2018
puisque la ligne est prévue
pour 2030 mais tout est fait
techniquement pour que la ligne puisse
arriver en 2024
on espère que les annonces du
gouvernement iront dans ce sens dans les
prochains mois enjeux politiques
économiques et sportifs l'avenir de la
ligne 18 ne sont plus si évident
aujourd'hui les arbitrages du
gouvernement sont attendus dans les
prochaines semaines